it's quite a strange feeling here
because the world has paid all this
attention to the country people dismiss
often some of the news that's coming in
about looming invasion it's something
that they've learned to live with for so
long but underneath once you scratch the
surface people open up and you see there
really is a genuine concern the question
that everybody is asking is will russia
invade my name is nils adler and i'm a
freelance journalist for al jazeera in
ukraine and between us i move from
cautious optimism to extreme pessimism
on whether russia will invade ukraine
i think what's important to remember
about this conflict is it didn't begin
as conventional warfare the ukrainian
army was in a terrible state in 2014
when the conflict began and so it was
volunteers people who had no experience
of fighting before and had to just pick
up a weapon and learn how to fight
the soldiers fighting right now this
trench warfare it's not the modern age
warfare we imagine with drones and
high-tech gadgets this is just soldiers
dug into a trench and they're just
fighting facing sniper fire and
artillery fight
i spoke to a soldier vladimir this was a
tough guy a tough soldier he began
slowly opening up talking a little bit
more about tactics and warfare but
slowly as we spoke i discovered he had
suffered this traumatic brain injury
twice he started to admit that maybe
there was a mental health aspect to this
i said
what do you do with all these feelings
and then he just pointed at his chest
and said i hold it all in here i tried
to get in contact with him again but i
was told he's not in a good place he's
really struggling to adapt
another forgotten aspect about this
conflict is the children in pulpasma
there was a young girl she was nine
years old for carolina she remembers the
shelling back in 2014 taking shelter in
this kind of makeshift bomb shelter that
the family had created and she is scared
that it's going to happen again as a
father of three and myself when i was
speaking to carolina i thought this is
not something children should have to be
thinking about
so i visited karaoke which is located
precariously close to the border with
russia now this is an incredibly
important city for ukraine both
economically but also because it's a
technological hub i met one
i.t specialist he was a avid
motorcyclist but when he realized that
there was an increased potential for an
invasion he sold his bike and he bought
a gun and now he works with his computer
but by his side is his gun and his body
armor and he's ready to go he says in
five minutes he would be ready to defend
his city
was mentioned by vladimir zelinski the
president of ukraine as a potential
first target for the russians should
they invade
[Music]
the ukrainian army is in a much better
state than it was back in 2014 and 2015.
but
this is russia we're talking about
[Music]
so civilians have really taken it upon
themselves to defend their city this is
not just about repelling an invasion of
their city but also keeping up a
resistance movement if they were
occupied
so right now russian troops have amassed
around ukraine's borders the americans
are saying innovation is imminent the
ukrainian president has asked for calm
the soldiers i spoke to on the front
line they're just focused on the same
thing and that's the separatists on the
other side in the other trenches
when they talk about the current
tensions they understand there's been an
increase in tensions but they can't
afford to be distracted by this that for
them is another world it's a world for
politicians to deal with for them
right now it's just about the trenches
it's about the muddy slog the everyday
slog of having to fight and face these
threats
[Music]
[Applause]